what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the conclusion of devil's
reign now in the last issue we basically
picked up or at least we had this event
where the purple man who was basically
being directed by wilson fisk had
essentially ensnared a good chunk of the
people in manhattan not all of them
right not everybody but a lot of them
like certainly enough of the avengers
have to face off against them now
there's also people like wolverine
different things like that now this is a
bit of an inconsistency here and here's
the reason why so when it comes to the
powers of the purple man remember
they're basically a result of pheromones
and so that's why people like wilson
fisk can overcome the power of the
purple man because their willpower is
strong enough wolverine technically
should not be ensnared the other thing
that we have to keep in mind though is
that this is not wolverine from the
maine marvel universe this is doctor
octopus wolverine and so looking at that
and looking at like the doctor octopus
incredible hulk both of which are from
alternate realities that seemingly they
have the same nature and structure of
like wolverine and the incredible hulk
but they lacked the components that
would help them to resist the power of
the purple man so it is kind of a way
for chip sadarsky to basically say maybe
in some form or fashion wolverine could
potentially be corrupted by the purple
man uh although given marvel's
traditional history again that's not
something we would readily see so i felt
like that was something worth pointing
out because i imagine a lot of people
who didn't pick up on the fact that this
is like the dr octopus alternate reality
version of wolverine would be like that
doesn't make any sense wolverine in the
main marvel universe should not be
caught up by the purple man you're right
it's just a different version of the
character but the bigger thing that goes
on here is that the superheroes who are
not ensnared by the purple man have to
contend with like the average person
right just your your normal average joes
and that's kind of a big deal because
they have to basically keep them at bay
they have to fight them off but they
don't want to hurt them at the same time
which is kind of the benefit of the
purple man here because it's basically
taking the nature of the superheroes and
using it against them the bigger thing
that goes on here though is that in the
middle of this fight matt murdock gets a
call that mike has been killed now
here's the thing when when matt murdock
gets this call he's basically told that
matt is dead right because at the end of
the day kirsten mcduffie does not know
that matt murdock is daredevil but as
you guys know matt's twin brother is
mike and so while matt's like okay
that's weird because i'm alive and well
he immediately picks up on the fact that
what kirsten actually saw was wilson
fisk killing mike murdock and so that's
when he realizes his brother's basically
dead now we called this right like
[Laughter]
we said mike murdock was going to die he
said like it's only a matter of time
before it happens because he's a
character that doesn't really serve a
purpose anymore and so marvel was like
we'll just get rid of him and just
replace him with somebody else it's one
of the things right you read mobile
comics enough long enough you can figure
out where they're going with particular
characters when they stop using them for
anything significant after a while but
the death of mike is not limited to how
it impacts matt in fact it'll also uh
it'll also impact the son of kingpin
butch and we'll talk about him here in a
little while but again doing what they
can hear at least the various
superheroes facing off against these
various villains daredevil ultimately
ends up taking off to basically find
wilson fisk with the intention of
killing wilson fisk because wilson fitz
had killed his brother matt now this is
an important thing and in a lot of ways
while it does kind of focus on sort of a
coming two of this battle between like
wilson fisk and daredevil the reality is
that this is a long time coming and
while there have been stories in the
past where like matt murdock just start
just gives wilson fist the business for
any number of reasons this has a kind of
finality to it right like the final
fight between like batman and the joker
or like the final fight between superman
and lex luthor this kind of seems to fit
that mold in a lot of different ways
because the reality here is that wilson
fisk has done a lot of things to get
back at daredevil he's dumped his
identity to the world technically it was
karen page who sold the identity of of
daredevil as uh as matt murdock but
nonetheless there's been a lot of things
that wilson fisk has done but this is
one of those things where it's kind of
the straw that broke the camel's back
wilson fisk in terms of killing mike
murdock believing he'd actually killed
matt at the same time doing all this
stuff in terms of like outlawing
superheroes and so on and so forth it's
one of those things where matt's like
enough right like this is like enough is
enough this guy's got to die now make no
mistake for matt it's personal right
it's a very personal thing because
wilson fisk going after superheroes or
whatever right that's just wilson fisk
doing what you ultimately would have
expected him to do as the mayor of new
york it was only a matter of time
killing the brother of matt murdock
that's breaking a line right that's
crossing a line that just is not
acceptable and so from there you
basically switch over to wilson fisk
meeting with typhoid mary now again the
two of them are basically a couple right
they're romantically involved with each
other but wilson fisk believing he'd
killed matt had told her we're done like
everything's done like it's just time to
go it's time to walk away the problem is
that as they're leaving they're suddenly
met by elektra now remember elektra is
kind of like a newer ish version of
daredevil now at the moment uh elektra
is kind of like this kind of daredevil
kind of knot
right she's just sort of doing her own
thing she had taken up the mantle when
daredevil was basically locked up and
just hadn't given it up right it was
just a way for marvel to kind of be like
we're elevating elektra beyond basically
the old frank miller days when she was
just the chick that was hot that matt
murdock probably banged a few times and
uh she's just a really good assassin
right and instead like they're moving
her into a different echelon where it's
really her and matt murdock working as a
team and in reality this is long overdue
right like elektra's literally been one
of those characters where she's just
been the same character forever so it's
cool to see marvel despite the fact that
it's something they haven't really done
since the 80s it's cool to see marvel
just elevate her and move her in a
different direction and give her like a
wholly different role that's far beyond
anything she's ever done before
particularly in the realm of daredevil
comics so i'm definitely digging that
but in the midst of this of course where
she's going to attack kingpin ultimately
matt's like no if kingpin dies today or
when he dies today i'll be the last
thing he sees and the crazy thing is
that like like wilson fisk doesn't know
what to do here because he thought he
killed matt and he's like why won't you
simply just die and ultimately of course
the two of them end up getting into a
skirmish now there are a couple things
that go on for example like dr octopus
is attacked by iron man and basically
knocked unconscious the fantastic four
step in and they kind of do their thing
which is cool i guess whatever uh but
like the the thing about this and really
one of the bigger things that take place
is that one of the really the last of
the purple man's children essentially
joseph ends up stepping up right ends up
coming into the equation now one of the
things that chipset darski has largely
built up and has really been a
contingent or a thing that's been going
on with the purple children since their
initial introduction is that they could
potentially overpower the purple man to
a degree he actually needed their powers
in order to basically expand on his own
but joseph there was always something
different about him and so ultimately
where he kind of makes his way and
you've just got this knocked down drag
out fight between like wilson fisk and
uh and daredevil and you've got elektra
fighting typhoid mary and all that kind
of stuff you've basically got the purple
man just literally seething with power
right i mean just just full of power
that the question that joseph asks once
he finds him is where where like where's
everybody else right like where are the
other kids and that's when the purple
man's like they're dead right like i
have their power now and there's nothing
you can do to stop me and so it
basically comes to a fight between a
purple man and his son now this is the
reason why this matters because what
this really is despite the fact that
this is a crossover event in marvel
comics and it focuses on a lot of the
superheroes it's the same thing we've
been saying since the beginning it's a
daredevil story that what this does is
it basically brings together and really
ties up all these loose ends involving
the daredevil mythos that's been going
on for quite some time since the return
of the purple children and all that kind
of stuff and there's even themes of this
that go all the way back into like brian
michael bendis new avengers specifically
with luke cage we'll talk about him here
in a second but it's one of those things
where it literally just wraps up the
daredevil mythos that's been going on
for quite some time and it just sort of
resets it that's one of the things that
i love about the idea of devil's reign
is because under any normal circumstance
and those of you guys who've been
reading comics for a long time you guys
know under any normal circumstance this
would have been wrapped up in a
daredevil comic and that would have been
it it would have been daredevil's issues
such and such through such and such and
that would have been it it's just one of
those things where making it like a
high-profile crossover event really sort
of elevates it and it's just like this
is basically the conclusion of this era
of daredevil and that's basically it and
that's why you could go back and read
all those comics charles soul and
everything going all the way up into the
current age until this story and it's
one cohesive era it's just one giant
daredevil epic and so at the end of that
of course again this giant fight between
uh between daredevil and kingpin it
begins to come to a head when basically
daredevil's just like thrown into a car
right and like really injured and then
he grabs the staff of kingpin which
contains a portion of the purple man's
power and when he says like i want you
to suffer kingpin like i want you to
suffer for all the things that you've
done i want you to think about all the
lives that you've destroyed he's just
like done right and then just goes back
to attacking daredevil because again
wilson fisk's fortitude right his his
just willpower overrides the power of
the purple man and that's why i say
kilgrave is a really really cool villain
but he only works under certain
circumstances that's why like the
jessica jones story in alias by bendis
was so good is because she was just a
young naive superhero who had no idea
what she was getting into when she
stumbled across the path of the purple
man because her willpower just wasn't
quite there yet she hadn't sort of she
hadn't really built herself up and
gained the confidence she needed in
order to overpower the influence of the
purple man now she does right if zebedee
kilgrave goes running up on jessica
jones she's gonna scoff off his powers
and then beat the hell out of him that's
exactly what's gonna happen
those two have beef but it's just it's
it's really really cool right this is
one of those cool elements and so
knowing that doesn't necessarily work
then we switch over to luke cage because
at this point this fight between uh
daredevil and wilson fisk is just an
intense fight just like a knock down
drag out fight and that's why you have
these moments where you have chip
siddarski sort of bouncing back and
forth between these scenarios where like
matt murdock cracks kingpin across the
face with his own cane right and
literally just like just creates these
gashing wounds and like wilson fisk is
just pummeling just absolutely attacking
daredevil as best he can they're
literally trying to kill each other
right it's just decades of hatred at
least in terms of comic publication
history coming to a head in this story
but for luke cage he makes this amazing
moment where what he does is he
basically takes his uh takes to the
device that's used to basically uh
ensure that he's not influenced by the
purple man and he gives it to joseph so
that way joseph won't be overpowered by
his own father and that's when kilgrave
is like that's a ridiculous thing and he
says mr cage kill my son and that's the
cool thing is because where luke cage
looks like he's getting ready to kill
him and destroy this kid this kid starts
lashing out and what luke cage says is
like you're not alone joseph like you
are not by yourself i know you feel like
you are but you are not tap into your
power son and use it now you would look
at this and you would say okay luke cage
should succumb to the power of the
purple man there's never been an
indication to show that he can't
overpower him but there actually is so
in brian michael bendis new avengers in
the first arc right breakout which i
don't know if we ever covered that but
bendis's new avengers was phenomenal
right it was like it's probably one of
the best brian michael bendis stories
ever before he lost his mind and started
going into bend to speak before he got
carried away with himself there was a
point because kilgrave was locked away
in the raft and luke cage was in his
presence he actually instructed luke
cage to basically start attacking the
superheroes and if i remember correctly
luke cage was able to overpower it he
was able to like override the influence
of the purple man and that was basically
it it took every ounce of inner strength
for him to do it
but he was still able to do it but with
joseph using every ounce and really it's
more emotion than anything else right
but like tapping into this power to
influence others he overrides the power
of his father and by overriding the
power of his dad he solidifies himself
as being stronger than the purple man
which is huge because of course as you
would expect where daredevil is on the
cusp of killing wilson fisk of course he
doesn't and things wrap up pretty
readily right like the various members
of the thunderbolts are arrested as you
would expect the thunderbolts were
always arrested right they're always
just locked up and taken to a prison
somewhere until they need to be used
again and then they're basically
released and they're sent out on
whatever task they have to go on right
so marvel's version of the suicide squad
uh of course again wilson fisk is
arrested the purple man is basically
taken away but what it does is it clears
the landscape here and it allows for
reshuffling of things because now you
have joseph as what's basically the
purple child you know where he still
like has his powers and that nobody else
really does he's just the last of the
the a person who can use the abilities
of the purple man so he's out there now
and presumably he's gonna become a good
guy so we won't know how his story
unfolds i mean presumably it'll appear
in some comic i don't really see them
making a solo comic for him specifically
even though i would probably read it i'd
read the first couple of the first arc
just to see whether or not it's good uh
and it may even be one of those things
where like jessica jones and luke cage
end up adopting him right end up taking
him in and just kind of he just goes
forward and does his own thing wilson
fisk where he's being arrested you end
up finding out that what's actually
going on here is that butch is one of
the people who arrested him butch being
his son and they basically end up taking
him away to what's essentially a safe
haven now when he gets there it's
actually butch bringing him to the
presence of the stromwins now here's the
thing the strong winds are basically new
for chip sidarski's work but we don't
really know a whole lot about them all
we really know is that they just kind of
appeared intermittently so like
daredevil volume 6 issue number 13 they
were part of of devil's reign but in
effect they were the ones who have
essentially gotten wilson fisk this far
in terms of him becoming mayor building
on what happened during secret empire
when like he was the one that was
keeping new york safe and so on and so
forth they seem to be the benefactors
and so what they end up saying here is
look like you got a couple options here
wilson fisk right the whole world knows
what you did uh but we have a lot of
reach and we have a lot of pool and we
can really help you know these these
charges that are being brought against
you we can help them go away the way
this will work though is that your son
will basically become the kingpin in the
city of new york and then we will
elevate you to the office of the
presidency we'll make you president of
the united states right using our
finances and so on and so forth we will
get you to that spot and that in reality
while you will be president you'll
essentially be working for us right like
we'll be telling you what kind of bills
you need to veto what kind of bills you
need to pass any executive orders that
need to be issued you know make no
mistake we'll be the ones controlling
the scene but you will get what you've
always wanted you'll become president
and you get this amazing moment where
wilson fisk you know where they
literally go to shake his hand and he's
just kind of like this is an interesting
offer now it's very similar to clone
conspiracy right when like the jackal
had shown up to wilson fisk with a
cloned version of vanessa and he freaked
out snapped her neck and was like that's
not my wife that's not vanessa that's
exactly what happens here right he says
my life has been successes and failures
i let my wife vanessa down in the sense
that she died and my son richard and now
to be president running a country he
says how could butch not look up to me
and respect me then because remember for
the longest time he didn't know butch
existed and then when butch finally came
around he was always trying to
demonstrate that he was like an
effective man but as a guy who was
essentially taking orders from the strom
ones even as mayor of new york that they
were the ones who got them there or at
least got him there that it was always
one of these things where he felt like
in the eyes of his son that he was a
follower that he wasn't a leader that
the wilson physical of old had largely
seemed to have gone away right and now
he was just doing what a good boy does
and so again he says how could butch not
look up to me and respect me then
running the greatest country in the
world and he says i've made mistakes i
won't make another and literally he's
like fist bows to no one and just starts
crushing everybody like literally starts
attacking everybody the guards the
strong ones the whole nine yards the
whole time he's like crushing the hand
of one of the strong ones and then
literally everybody just gets taken out
right like they're just basically done
and gone and that's when he's like
here's what's gonna happen right he
tells his son like when it sounds like
what are you doing he's like the exact
same thing you're doing like you're
joining in here he's like look a fisk
does not bow to anyone a fist does not
take orders from anyone a fisk does as
fisk pleases and that's the way that it
is because we're powerful enough because
we have enough conviction only a fool
would come to a fisk and say work for me
and i will give you x y and z when a
fisk knows full well they can just take
it and he's like that's the legacy that
i leave to you he was like you are now
the kingpin of new york i'm out i'm
going to do my thing but i leave you
this legacy live up to the legacy of the
fisk do not let anybody out there tell
you what you will or will not do if
there is something that you want take it
and those who are too weak will let you
have it and those who are too strong
will be stupid enough to challenge you
so do what you please that's the way we
as fisks operate he's like after all
these years this is my gift to you boy
your inheritance and walks away now
during this conversation what he had let
slip is that he had murdered matt
murdock and that ultimately this is when
butch realizes it was not matt murdock
the kingpin killed it was mike murdock
it was his friend and so as a result of
that the question's kind of up in the
air what happens next does butch live up
to the legacy of the fisk or does butch
basically become a good guy and actually
turn against his father does he become
an ally of daredevil we're not entirely
sure but the week following this this is
when we start to get a kind of uh kind
of follow-up this is really more of like
a epilogue it's just tied directly into
the story and really gives us the next
direction for the daredevil series which
is that elektra nachios and and matt
murdock are essentially teaming up to
form the fist that what they are going
to do is basically become this kind of
antithesis of the hand now in recent
years and not even really recent years
but like in years past that was the role
that was played by the cast the reality
of this is that they're not really a
part of the picture anymore and so
because of that something has to stand
against the role of the hand always
influencing and always involving things
but the reason why the hand is chosen
make no mistake the reason why that
group is chosen as being being really
the main enemy of the fist is because
this is taking daredevil back to the old
school days it's tying back into the
frame frank miller days even if it's not
necessarily retreading water it's
bringing back the classic daredevil but
by a different means and instead of
elektra just being some assassin out
there that matt murdock crosses paths
with and touches naughty bits with every
so often instead like she's an ally
right she's working with him and the two
of them are gonna go forward with their
fists and then do their whole thing so
that's cool and i'm actually interested
to see what direction this ends up going
in as for wilson fisk and the way this
basically ends wilson fisk ends up doing
what he always felt like he should have
done before but the reality here is that
with him operating as the kingpin of
crime that he always basically took
directions from other people that even
when he was operating his kingpin and
even when he was to a degree doing his
own thing his life was motivated by
trying to defeat daredevil or swimming
along those lines and seemingly for the
first time he's literally taking his
life under his own under his own wing
and just like taking uh taking typhoid
mary and just like going out into the
world where their journey takes them i'm
not entirely sure but i would surmise
the reason why they're doing this the
reason why marvel's doing this doesn't
really have much to do with the nature
of kingpin and marvel comics is because
kingpin's in the mcu and the last we saw
him he was shot in the face by echo at
least presumably anyway right the camera
panned off and then we heard a gunshot
and then maybe kingpin's dead but
supposedly he's gonna come back is what
everybody's saying right he's supposed
to reappear in the mcu series in the
actual marvel cinematic universe series
on disney plus which fingers crossed is
going to be mature just like it was on
on netflix and likely when that happens
they'll bring him back in some capacity
similar to that right so when that
series launches or when yeah when that
series launches on disney plus and like
the kingpin returns this is when you'll
see marvel be like the kingpins back in
the comics you know like that's gonna be
their whole thing right so but that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end i did love devil's reign don't
get me wrong i thought it was a
phenomenal story i mean it's just
beautifully written and beautifully done
uh i i thought it was incredible but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace